All right.
My friends, let's look at some stunning polling
numbers, Donald Trump's favorite pollster,
Rasmussen, is a right wing friendly pollster,
has a new poll out where Donald Trump is down
by 12 points to Joseph R. Biden Junior.
When other polls don't look good for Trump,
Trump often says, look at Rasmussen wrasse
Musan does good polling.
Well, here is Rasmussen's latest poll with
our M.G.
Research saying Trump is down 12 to Biden,
48 to 36, with nine percent not sure and six
percent supporting some other candidate.
Now, important to understand that there are
15 percent here that are either for some third
party candidate or aren't sure yet if they
mostly consolidate around Trump in November.
That can get Trump close enough where even
he could lose the popular vote by a few points,
but still win the Electoral College.
We saw that in 2016.
But the reason that this poll matters is that
last week when CNN said, hey, we have a poll
done with us, SRS reliable, reputable pollster
says Trump is down 14.
Trump said it was fake.
Had his lawyer send a cease and desist letter
to CNN, demanded an apology and demanded a
retraction.
We now have a traditionally right wing pollster
saying, well, it's not a 14 point lead for
Biden, but it's a 12 point lead for Biden.
And in addition, we have an Abacus data or
data poll
from yesterday, which also has this as a 14
point lead for Joe Biden.
So what is our takeaway?
The takeaway is nothing.
Every single one of you of us, me, you have
everybody.
Every one of us has to vote, no matter what
any poll says, because Donald Trump is desperate
and he will do anything he can to get reelected.
They are going to try to suppress the vote.
They are going to try to come up with some
October surprise.
We talked earlier in the show about maybe
some emergency use vaccine.
We can assume nothing if in your state Biden
is polling ahead by 30 points.
What do you do?
You go and vote because we can't take a chance.
Now, let's look at some stunning state polls.
In the meantime, an admittedly left leaning
P.P. poll has Biden plus 14 in New Mexico.
An epic
MRA poll has Biden, plus 16 in Michigan.
Now, remember, none of this changes anything
about what we have to do but understand how
2016 went.
And then if you look at 2016, where Donald
Trump won Michigan by point two percent, point
two percent.
If Trump goes from winning Michigan by point
two percent to losing it by 16 or even 15
or even eight or even five.
That signals a massive change from the 2016
election because it probably means a bunch
of states aren't going to go Donald Trump's
way.
Another important state to look at is Iowa.
Donald Trump won Iowa by 10 in 2016.
The latest poll from the Des Moines Register,
good pollster has Trump up only one.
Trump won by 10 in Iowa in 2016.
Currently, Trump is winning by one.
In Iowa, we have 50 individual elections when
we do a presidential
election.
It is a national choice, but they are 50 individual
elections.
They're correlated, though.
If Trump's margin of victory in Iowa goes
from 10 to one, it's a signal about other
states.
But again, third time I'm saying this and
you're going to hear this from me a lot.
Our mission, our mission, our assignment individually
is we vote no matter what state we're in.
We vote no matter what the polls say.
If in mid-October the stock market spikes
and Trump claims he got us a vaccine, it could
push him to victory.
And then we have four more years of Trump
Trump selecting Supreme Court justices, Trump
putting in more federal and appeals court
judges.
So we need to be prepared for something in
October.
We need to be ready to deal with it, meaning
every single person must plan to vote.
Now, I want to focus
in a little more specifically on Arkansas.